a good day Jeff Cape here from evergreen
in Toronto at the World Economic Forum
looking to explore the subject of
environmental issues and how kind of
change the Copenhagen affairs have
essentially failed in a very substantial
way the agenda going forward i think is
to try to find a way to enable you just
what governments urban issues to be the
core way to move change nation-states
have not found the will the legal
mechanisms to affect change but use
abilities and music urban governments
both of the capacity and to make quick
decisions and to enable and affect
change on the ground through huge
populations and cities are much more
effectively much more efficiently and
enable social change and behavioral
change any citizens far more effectively
so that they look the quick agenda i
think is to find a way to bring best
practices of governments national
governments together around the climate
change in china thank you